hello everyone and welcome to another
game we're going to cover from the nor
ultibox norway championship
uh it's a classical game from round four
magnus carlson versus fabiano caruana
and they already played their second
classical game and uh
i don't know if you know uh what
happened in there but we're going to
talk about it after the game
so here magnus has the white pieces fabi
has black uh number one
and number two player in the world in
classical chess uh playing
one of the uh the oldest most
traditional lines in chess
so hope you guys enjoy it uh so and uh
thank you all for the
welcoming messages there are like 2 500
of them
i i like uh so many of them i've tried
to read them all
and thank you so much for that i didn't
see you suggest all that many games but
you know thank you for all the all the
best wishes now getting back to the game
uh magnus with the white pieces opens
with
d4 and we're gonna have a very very nice
line of the
nimzo indian defense knight f6 with c4
e6
uh and knight to c3 magnus invites fabi
to go for the name so indian which he
does bishop to b4
and the queen to c2 these are the two
most popular options for
for white here that white goes queen to
c2 and fabi castles
with a3 challenging the bishop and the
bishop captures on c3
although it seems like a good idea to go
back with the bishop why would you give
your bishop for a knight
black almost exclusively plays this year
this has been
played in you know well in a few games
but
uh basically sorry this has been played
in a few games
but basically you character on c3 uh we
have queen captures and now b6 being the
main line here uh we have
d5 by fabi uh we have bishop to g5 now
putting pressure on the knight
uh also putting pressure on the center
so d
captures on c5 and the queen captures on
c5 now grabbing that pawn and b6
that's not a b6 uh b6 preparing to
develop
the light square bishop as you usually
do in him so you want to
get get get this setup optimally let's
say 97 develop the bishop hopefully the
b7
uh play c5 get the rook into the game
and so on
so here rook to d1 by magnus and then
now comes
bishop a6 uh bishop to b7 has been
played in one game it was actually
played
this year in croatian championship uh
between jovanich and zeltchich
won that game but other than that game
bishop to a6 is played exclusively here
uh attacking the queen and now uh you
don't want to give
a black free development that that'd be
silly of course you you do have the
white pieces
and you want to keep an eye on the
bishop you don't want to allow black to
freely play knight d7 rook c8 c5 and so
on
so here queen to a4 is still putting
pressure on the bishop not allowing
fabi to develop this knight with h6
challenging the bishop to bishop to h4
and now queen to d7 fabio offers a queen
trade
and magnus declines with queen to c2 uh
we have queen to c6 now offering the
queen trade a second time
and if you decline here then you give
white a beautiful
square for the queen like if you go back
then the queen gets uh
uh well i mean stays here the bishop is
on an excellent diagonal the knight can
jump into e4
uh it's going to be an excellent
position for uh for black so instead
queen captures on c6 here magnus trades
knight captures on c6 and now bishop
captures an f6
uh magnus decides to uh give up the
bishop pair in order to mess up fabi's
pawn structure we have g
captures on f6 and now knight f3 is a
known move here but here we have
e3 by magnus and it is as of move 15
that we have a completely new game
and this theoretical struggle uh in the
nimzo indian
uh so fabi captures the bishop of course
we have bishop captures on f1
king captures and now knight the a5 you
you want to get the rook into the game
push c5 and you want to
fully develop everything so knight to f3
by magnus and now
knight to c4 putting pressure on the
pawn here and
while you could defend this spawn uh in
uh
well in a lot of ways you could actually
defend it but you could also play rook
to c1 attack the knight and if the
knight captures you can capture on c7
uh but magnus uh probably of course had
this all analyzed at home
and the thought that rook to b1 poses
most problems for black so rook to b1
uh and now finally c5 this is uh
uh always a question whether you first
play rook fc8 whether you play rook
eight to see it whether you push c5
right away so these are all
uh great questions you know uh for for
someone to answer
but uh you know we'll we we of course
cannot say as uh you have to like
truly truly analyze this with with the
deep engine analysis and then
uh decide what's best here and i have no
idea what kind of equipment these guys
have
so here uh first c5 by fabi immediately
uh
taking advantage of this center and king
e2 magnus brings the king into the game
we have rook f the c8 now getting rook
into the game
and magnus goes rook h to c1 he brings
his rook into the game as well
now putting pressure on the knight
knight to d6 and only now captures on c5
with captures captures and
now rook to c2 keeping an eye on the b2
pawn while preparing rook b to c1 to put
pressure on the c5 pawn
uh king to f8 fabi starts bringing his
king into the game as well
and now knight to d2 uh the knight is
now coming
deeper into the game we have c4 by uh
fabi
uh now the knight is sufficiently
defended and the magnus goes rook
b to c1 saying okay now the pawn is
attacked three times there is not much
for you to do
and now rook ate the b8 fabi says okay
you can capture this but after all he
said and then i'm going to capture
on b2 and while this is possible this
will come with
check and magnus doesn't like that so
first magnus plays king to f3
and now we have a very interesting uh
move here by fabi here fabi played c3
and he gave up
a pawn but to understand fabi c3
we first have to ask ourselves what
happens if you just don't give up upon
well let's say you try playing something
else let's say you play king e7 you you
improve the position of the king
uh white just goes and trades everything
knight captures on c4
knight captures we have rook captures
rook captures rook captures
and after rook captures this pawn you
have rook to c7 check picking up
the a7 pawn as well white has a past a
pawn the king protects the f2 pawn and
white has
amazing winning chances so this is what
happens here on the other hand if you
try something like a5
to keep the pawn protected uh from such
attacks it doesn't really
keep the pawn protected because after
again all is
said and done here after a capture fest
occurs on c4 captures captures captures
real captures on b2 we get rook c5 you
still lose the pawn
and you will still enjoy the exact same
end game so this is what would happen
so here after this king to f3 move uh
fabi decided that he doesn't like this
end game and he decided to play this end
game instead so c3 uh he's now down upon
but at least magnus
will not have a past pawn uh and now
magnus captures with b
uh captures on c3 and now rook to c5
uh we have c for by magnus the pawn is
now defended three times here so it's
very safe
and f5 by fabi we have king to e2 and
king to e7 now we have king to d3
and now king to d7 uh with rook to c3
adding more protection here uh and rook
to c6
uh we have c5 now magnus continues
advancing with this past c
pawn uh and now comes knight to e8 now
you can shift the knight around maybe to
f6 maybe to d5
with knight to f3 now threatening knight
the e5 check to pick up material here
and of course rook to a6 getting the
rook out of harm's way
uh knight to e sorry knights the e5 uh
with
check uh uh for forcing black to move
back or fourth
uh king to e7 and now comes king to e2
magnus still wants to keep his king very
safe before he
he starts uh doing anything rash uh we
have
knight to f6 preparing to again shift
the knight over to d5 or
e4 if needed and now rook one to c2
not allowing any rook to be check ideas
in in the future
so knights to d5 shifting the knight and
now rook to d3
so keeping the the rook defended we have
rook back to c8
and now rook to b3 so uh the pawn is the
defended uh and now magnus also might be
having access to this to the b7 square
so rook to c7 the fabio of course
prevents that and now
rook the c4 just grabbing more space
making a nice rook lift
and asking fabi what will you play uh
fabi plays rook to a5
puts more pressure on the c5 pawn and
now just
knight back to d3 magnus defense
and here uh you could uh try a lot of
different approaches you could try h5
uh you could maybe try rook to a6 bring
the rook over to c6 to put
more pressure on the c5 pawn but fabi
decides to go for a different plan he
pushes
e5 and now he says okay you either give
up the c5 pawn for the e5 pawn
or i'm just going to push this one all
the way to e4 and then i'm really going
to have a
a massive position so here magnus of
course
goes for the capture knight captures on
e5
uh with rook a captures on c5 captures
on c5 captures and
rook to b7 check now the thing is yes
you do get king to e6 in
attacking the knight so you don't have
time to capture the a7 pawn
uh but you do have time to capture the
f7 pawn with
the knight which is exactly what magnus
does so knight captures on f7
and now you're already up two pawns and
here rook to a5 this was fabi's plan
give up the h6 pawn as well and then
grab the a3 pawn at least you get
to start pushing your uh pushing your a7
pawn
however magnus decides uh it's not maybe
not uh
ideal to give black this opportunity
even though knight captures on h6 is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
uh magnus decides to go for the most
more human approach
knight to d8 with check king the d6 and
now rook to b3
he says okay these pawns are weak i'm
just going to defend my a3 pawn and not
give you any counter play whatsoever
so rook to a6 and now comes knight back
to f7 with
check the rook will now defend the h6
pawn so the king can freely move king c5
and now knight to e5 uh we have
h5 by fabi and now king the d2 uh with
h4 and now knight to d3 with check
king to c4 uh the king is very safe
there
so you don't have to worry about getting
checkmated as uh
the knight is nicely covering all of the
squares so king the c2
and now rook to d6 uh by fabi
rook the d6 uh is one option uh for
example if you try something like knight
to b6 it still won't help you because
you get the rook to be for
check and well there's the problem of
this pawn so king d5
uh for example king d5 you're going to
get rook to d4 check
kink to e6 and now you might even lose
the rook for example here
uh knight c5 check or even if you go
here
knight to the b4 check again uh wins the
winthrop and you're still still going to
win this h5 pawn
so instead fabi tries to go with a
different plan uh of defense
rook to d6 uh and now comes a move
knight to f4 and after this knight to a4
move
it was on move 51 that fabiano corona
resigned the game
and magnus wins a classical game with
black in the nimso
indian defense in the classical
variation so very very exciting stuff
and here
you resign because you're simply down
too much material and you don't have any
good moves
uh like if you if you trade the captures
captures uh
white will not capture uh sorry about
that white will not recapture with the
pawn
uh but rather rook before check and
after the king moves you're just going
to capture with the rook you're still up
so much material
uh black was unsuccessful in messing up
any of your uh pawn structure
and if you instead don't go for the
night trade if you try and keep the
knight let's say you try something else
uh instead of capturing let's say you
bring the knight over to f6 uh you're
still going to get
uh rogue before check king to c5 and now
even
knight to d3 check the h pawn falls and
you're simply going to be down too much
material so even though it's a classical
game
fabio resigns and an excellent victory
for magnus in in round four
of the ultibox norway championship as
this is uh this is a classical game and
as you know two of them played
uh two of them have played uh uh 12
games of classical chess in the world
chess championship match
and uh all of them have ended in the
draw which is which is pretty crazy
so yeah a great uh great game by magnus
and just so i don't forget
uh and also there is a question uh for
the end of this game
uh where did fabi go wrong because you
know they teach us in chess
you can just win a game if and none of
the players have gone wrong so
where did fabi go wrong this game that
is a question for you
and also uh let's not forget the
standings uh after all the rounds of
this tournament have been played i'm
gonna
keep it updated but uh these are these
are not the standings after this round
these are the standings after all of the
rounds so far have been played
so uh sorry about that uh so there we
have it
magnus is leading the tournament with 16
and a half out of 25
followed by alireza ferrugia with 15 and
a half out of 26 then lebanon
with 13 out of 26 fabiana corona with 12
and a half
young shisht of duda with eight and a
half and arientari not having uh
a lot of luck so far with one and a half
out of 24.
uh i tried following some of the games
during my stay in the hospital but i was
like
like i i checked some of the games but i
was too
uh you know to to too high up on the
good stuff to
make sense of anything so i didn't even
bother uh so
all the games are new to me i'm really
just experiencing it
all from the start and it seems to be
seems to be like a very exciting event
but yeah that's uh the game i do hope
you enjoyed it
i would like to thank thomas arnold uh
patrick colin walls
nina webb kyle weatherly and tim burdick
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this event uh
you know as much as i can
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and don't
forget if i said
anything weird we're gonna blame it on
the anesthesia see you soon